info intox et avec anthony st léger
bonjour anthony man jour les tensions
entre la france et le mali qui
nourrissent une fois de plus la guerre
des images sur les réseaux sociaux
effectivement un des derniers exemples
en date ce sont ces trois ces cinq
photos que l'on va découvrir ensemble
regarder on y voit des véhicules en
militaires en sable et endommagé aussi
on voit par exemple des munitions ou
encore cette photo où l'on voit dans
l'arrière-plan ce véhicule c5 clichés
ils ont été mis en ligne sur facebook à
la fin du mois de janvier via notamment
je dis bien notamment cette publication
qui cumule plus de 1200 mention j'aime
et à chaque fois ce sont les mêmes types
de légende en l'occurrence vous le voyez
c'est écrit ici le fait que ce serait le
bilan d'une offensive menée par l'armée
algérienne à proximité du niger contre
des mercenaires à la solde de la france
qui ont quitté la libye à destination du
mali ça nous fait faire un petit peu de
géographie et plusieurs d'entre eux
seraient même est décédé dans cette
attaque il s'agit de fausses
informations comme souvent en fait ces
photos ont été sortis de leur contexte
effectivement et une fois encore raphaël
c'est la fameuse recherche d'image
inversée qui nous a permis de retrouver
l'origine des photos seins je vous
renvoie sur le site des observateurs
pour savoir comment faire les cinq
photos de ce soir proviennent de
d'articles de médias africains locaux
fiable on a par exemple agence
nigérienne de presse ou encore actu
niger et pour cause puisque ces images
elles nous viennent tout droit du niger
elles ont été publiées le 29 janvier
dernier date à laquelle les forces de
défense nigériane ont répondu à une
attaque terroriste mené près de diffa
c'est le point rouge que l'on voit ici
au sud du niger à la frontière avec le
nigeria dans le sud du pays donc et
c'est un article de nos confrères de rfi
en haoussa l'une des langues parlées à
la fois au niger au nigeria d'ailleurs
et qui va nous en apprendre un peu plus
sur le contexte le ministère nigérien de
la défense a publié un communiqué
effectivement le 29 janvier le jour même
de la tacc ou sept véhicules donc de
l'organisation état islamique en afrique
de l'ouest ont été vaincus par l'armée
nigérienne une dizaine de djihadistes
ont été tués et trois blessés et aucun
membre des forces de défense nigériane
n'a été blessé
donc je vous le disais ou des comptes y
voit une attaque une en tout cas de
soldes de mercenaires français il s'agit
tout simplement d'une riposte contre des
terroristes au niger et ça ce n'est pas
rare le contexte je vous le disais de
tension et dans je vous parlait
récemment de ces images décontextualisés
attribué au mali là où en fait il
s'agissait de présentation des suspects
de l'assassinât du président haïtien
journée le moïse outre faux seins fois
la cible cette fois la ministre
française désarmé florence parly week
est aujourd'hui et demain d'ailleurs au
niger pour discuter de l'évolution de
l'opération barkan florence parly qui à
qui on sait la junte malienne au pouvoir
a fait comprendre qu'il valait mieux se
taire elle qui les a accusés de
provocation connaît la suite les
déclarations de jean yves le drian
l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur français
depuis ce jour donc ce tweet regardez en
un mot la france aurait installé ses
bases dans la za wadan territoire au
nord du mali on le rappelle en accord
avec la sema qui regroupe des groupes à
touareg armés touareg et nationalistes
arabes en accord aussi avec les
djihadistes d'aqmi danse à 10 dans
sardines ou d'humour joie où l'on
rappelle que ces deux derniers groupes
d'ailleurs n'existe plus en tant que
telle et au passage les remercierai de
s'être désolidarisé de cette junte au
pouvoir honte de l'afrique je cite
toujours selon ce tweet contenu assez
choquant a même si le tweet paraît bien
officiel oui parce qu'on a ce fameux
badge bleu que l'on voit ici la photo de
profil de florence parly sauf que
évidemment c'est l'un des premiers
indices qui doit quand même interpellé
c'est le contenu assez grossier au delà
ça donc je disais plusieurs éléments
visuels mais quand vous regardez plus
près vous voyez qu'il ya un f majuscule
et un pm majuscule est en fait le compte
officiel de florence parly présente un
petit f et un petit p il est aussi les
mots italie et azawad qui sont écrit en
minuscule on se dit que quand même quand
on a un service de communication du
ministre français est désarmé on
écrirait pas cela comme ça et puis par
exemple la date que vous voyez ici le 31
et le mois de janvier qui sont collés ce
qui n'est pas le cas quand vous publiez
un tweet et puis surtout une marque de
fabrique de ce type d'un phoque c'est
tout simplement que ce sont souvent des
captures d'écran comme celle ci et non
des liens vers les tweets et pour cause
puisque les tweets elle n'existe pas
donc pas de lien vers le compte de la
personne concernés ce tweet est donc
très certainement le fruit d'un
générateur automatique de faux tweets
comme il en est disponible sur internet
gratuitement précisons toutefois que
cette réunion elle a bien eu lieu à rome
en italie et qu'un accord a été trouvé
entre les groupes armés du nord et la
junte au pouvoir au mali moralité
toujours aller dans les détails merci
anthony st léger pour info intox on se
retrouve nous dans à 4 minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans parisien
[Musique]